[Music]
the family goes in this court seeking
justice
for all of us in america
america and the rest of the world have
been watching as the trial of derek
shovin the former police officer accused
of killing george floyd
has continued here in minneapolis over
the next half hour sky news will bring
you the testimonies
from the second week of proceedings and
this week saw police officers testifying
against
derek chauvin breaking the so-called
blue wall of silence
among them the most high-profile witness
so far madaria aradondo the police chief
of minneapolis and a warning the
evidence contains graphic descriptions
and images
of the death of george floyd close to
midnight
a community member had contacted me
and said chief
um almost
verbatim but said chief have you seen
the video
of your officer choking and killing that
that man
at 38th chicago and so once i heard um
that statement i
just knew it wasn't the same milestone
camera video
that i had saw and um
eventually within minutes after that i
saw
for the first time uh what is now known
as the
the bystander video it is my firm belief
that the
one singular incident we will be judged
forever on
will be our use of force and so while it
is
absolutely imperative that our officers
go home at the end of their shift
we want to make sure and ensure that our
community members go home too
and so sanctity of life is absolutely
vital that that is the pillar
for our use of force is what you see in
exhibit 17
in your opinion within minneapolis
police departmental policy
5-300 authorizing the use
of reasonable force it is not and why
not
that is that is uh
it has to be objectively reasonable we
have to take into account
uh the circumstances information the
threat
to the officer the threat to others
and we um the severity of that
so that is not a part of our policy
that is not what we teach and that
should be condoned
when do you believe or do you have a
belief as to when this restraint the
restraint on the ground that you viewed
should have stopped
once mr floyd and this is based on my
viewing of the
the videos um once mr floyd had stopped
resisting
and certainly once he was
in distress and trying to verbalize that
um
that that should have stopped um there's
there's an initial reasonableness in
trying to
just get him under control over the in
the first few seconds
but but once there was no longer any
resistance
and clearly when mr floyd was no longer
responsive and even motionless
to continue to apply
that level of force
to a person proned out
handcuffed behind their back
that that in no way shape or form is
anything that uh
is by policy is not part of our training
and it is certainly not part of our
ethics or our values the court also
heard whether putting a knee on a
suspect's neck is part of minneapolis
police protocol
johnny murcill is the officer in charge
of use of force training a
class that derek shovin attended any
restraint
he told the jury had to be proportional
to any resistance being offered
sir is this an mpd trained
neck restraint no sir
has it ever been not to my neck
restraint no sir
is this a mpd authorized restraint
technique
uh knee on the neck would be something
that does happen in use of course that
isn't
unauthorized and under what
circumstances would that be authorized
how long can you do that
i don't know if there's a time frame it
would depend on the circumstance of the
time
which would include what the type of
resistance you're getting from the
subject that you're putting money on
right and so if there was uh say for
example
the subject was under control and
handcuffed
would this be authorized i would say no
how long
then is the person the subject to be
left in the prone handcuffed position
once they're compliant
uh it depends on the circumstances that
you're involved in with this person in
the
surrounding environment so assume the
circumstances that i
just stated the subject is prone
handcuffed and no longer resisting
i think it's reasonably necessary of the
time to do it then you should
get them in a different position what
position is that
it depends on circumstances but uh
you can put them in the recovery
position on their side you can sit them
up you can stand them up
and why would you want to put them into
a different position
there is the possibility and risk that
um that some people have
difficulty breathing when the handcuffs
are behind their back and they're on the
stomach
a police sergeant from los angeles who's
investigated more than 2
000 cases of use of force by police was
called as an expert witness
jody steiger told the jury that having
reviewed everything in this case
he believed derek chauvin's use of force
was excessive
and based upon your review of these
materials and in light of the graham
factors
what is your opinion as to the degree of
force
used by the defendant on mr floyd on
the date in question my opinion was that
the force was excessive
i'd like to then focus your attention to
the gram versus conor factors you
indicated that
one of the factors that you consider is
the severity of the offense
being investigated is that right yes sir
and do you recall what was the severity
of the offense being investigated here
uh if i remember correctly it was uh
mr floyd was accused of uh having a
counterfeit 20
bill and how does the
that particular offense or the severity
of the offense
relate to the appropriateness of the
force to be used against him
typically in a normal
situation where you're dealing with
someone that's a counterfeiter or
someone who's
using a counterfeit bill typically you
wouldn't even expect to use any type of
force uh when you're looking at in the
in the conor standard the severity of
the offense is the
label of the offense be it a misdemeanor
or felony
is that important in some cases yes um
what do you find more important than the
label of the offense
uh the person's actions and so would it
be fair to describe the
counterfeit 20 bill as a fairly low
level offense
yes and in the in the conner world then
that would
justify a lesser force is that right yes
getting back to the circumstances of
this case um
this appear to be the bystanders that
were gathered watching the defendant
apply force to mr floyd yes it does
when you reviewed the body worn cameras
did you see anybody throw any rocks or
bottles
no i did not did you see anyone attack
physically attack the officers
no i did not did you hear uh foul
language or name calling
there was a name calling yes but uh and
some foul language
but that was about the most of it did
that factor into your analysis
no why not because i did not
perceive them as being a threat and why
is that
because they were merely filming and
they were
most of it was their concern for mr
floyd this week sky news has been
bringing continuous coverage and
analysis of the trial of derrick chauvin
the former police officer accused of
killing george floyd in may last year
we're looking back at the testimony of
some of the witnesses who were called to
the stand to give evidence in the second
week of proceedings
this week saw medical experts provide
their analysis of the most contested
aspect of this trial
the cause of george floyd's death
bradford langenfeld is the doctor
who tried to resuscitate mr floyd in
hospital he told the jury he believed
a lack of oxygen was the most likely
cause of death
and a warning the evidence contains
graphic descriptions and images
of the death of george floyd there was
virtually no cardiac activity
and and at that point in the absence of
any
apparent reversible cause and because
mr floyd had been in arrest for by this
time 60 minutes i determined that the
likelihood of any
meaningful outcome was far below 1
and that we would not be able to
resuscitate mr floyd and so
i then pronounced him dead
and doctor uh was your leading theory
then for the cause
of mr floyd's cardiac arrest oxygen
oxygen deficiency that was
one of the more likely possibilities i
felt that
at the time based on the information i
had it was
more likely than the other possibilities
and and doctor is there another name for
death by oxygen deficiency asphyxia
is a commonly understood term you uh
consider
uh the possibility of toxins for example
being responsible for mr floyd's cardiac
arrest including
potentially drugs in the sense that it
might have informed our care yes
i didn't there was again no report that
this patient had for example
overdosed on a specific medication such
as a
calcium channel blocker or any other
medication for which there
might be a very specific antidote um
and so in that sense i didn't feel that
there was a
specific toxin that we could give a
medication for that would readily
reverse
his arrest
and what about then hypoxia
so hypoxia being again
one of the most common causes of pea
asystole just
in general i did
then as i mentioned used the ultrasound
to look in the abdomen and did not see
any evidence of hemorrhage there was no
obvious significant external trauma that
would have suggested that he suffered
anything that could produce bleeding
sufficient to lead to a cardiac arrest
and so based on the history that was
available to me
i felt that hypoxia was
of the more likely possibilities and
hypoxia as an explanation for his
cardiac arrest meaning
uh oxygen oxygen insufficiency
correct hypoxia is the lack of oxygen to
the brain correct
correct and there are many things that
cause hypoxia that would still be
considered
asphyxiation agreed correct drug use
certain drugs can cause hypoxia agreed
specifically fentanyl that's correct
how about methamphetamine it can
combination of the two yes
a world-renowned breathing expert told
the court he believes george floyd died
from a
low level of oxygen dr martin tobin told
the jurors he'd watched videos of the
arrest hundreds of times
in order to create a diagram showing how
crucial the officer's positions
on mr floyd were have you formed an
opinion to a reasonable degree of
medical certainty
on the cause of mr floyd's death yes i
have
uh would you please tell the jury what
that opinion or opinions
are yes mr floyd
died from a low level of oxygen
and this caused damage
to his brain that we see and it also
caused
a pea arrhythmia that caused his heart
to stop
the cause of the low level of oxygen
was shallow breathing
small breaths small tidal volumes
shallow breaths that weren't able to
carry
the air through his lungs down to the
essential
areas of the lungs that get oxygen into
the blood and get rid of the carbon
dioxide that's the alveoli at the bottom
of the lung
what happened in the case of mr floyd
that relates to the shallow breathing
that resulted in his low oxygen so there
are a number of forces that led to
that he's the size of his breath
became so small and so there are a
series of forces higher up
that are leading to that and the main
forces that are
going to lead to the shallow breath are
going to be
that he's turned prone on the street
that he has the handcuffs in place
combined with the street
and then that he has a knee on his neck
and then that he has a knee on his back
and on his side all of these four forces
are ultimately going to result in the
low tidal volume which gives you the
shallow breaths that we saw here and
so let's walk through exhibit 949 brad
if you could advance
and doctor tell us what we're seeing
okay yep
now you can see the car is being rotated
you're able to see
uh officer chauvin you're able to see
officer king and then officer lane down
at his feet
you see underneath mr floyd and now the
car has been rotated now the car has
been removed
and so you're able to see how they're
positioned at different points
in terms of with officer shaven with his
left knee on the neck
his right knee on mr floyd's arm and
chest
and then you can see here officer lane
holding his legs and then
you can see officer king with his knee
on his torso what is the effect of the
handcuffs
in the context of what happened to mr
floyd the handcuffs
are extremely important in mr floyd
but the handcuffs on their own just
handcuffs per se are not that important
it must be the handcuffs combined with
the street
and it's because of the positioning of
the handcuffs at the back
then how he's manipulated with the
handcuffs
by both officer chavan and by officer
king
how they manipulate the handcuffs and
they're pushing the handcuffs
into his back and pushing them high
then on the other side you have the
street
so the street is playing a crucial part
because he's against a hard asphalt
street
so the way they're pushing down on his
handcuffs combined with the street
his left side and that's particularly
the left side we see that it's like the
left side is in a vise
so he was being squashed between the two
sides
and so this meant that he couldn't
exert his pump handle because i mean
this three totally blocked
his pump handle there was no way he
could do any
front to back movement and again the way
they were pressing in on the back there
was absolutely no way
that he could do any front to back
movement then in addition
because of the knee that was rammed in
against
the the left side of his chest sometimes
the knee was down
on the arm or in against the chest
so this would have the same effect so
basically
on the left side of his lung
it was almost like a surgical
pneumonectomy it was
almost to the effect as if a surgeon had
gone in and removed the lung not quite
but
along those lines so there was virtually
very little opportunity for him
to be able to get any air to move into
the left side of his chest
one of the most important testimonies in
the trial came from dr andrew baker
the medical examiner who conducted the
post-mortem examination of george floyd
he told the court he stood by his
initial conclusion
that george floyd's cause of death was
homicide
we did find from the toxicology amounts
of fentanyl and methamphetamine
in the results from the lab that is
correct
uh you didn't mention either fentanyl or
math in mr floyd's system
you mentioned those but you don't list
either either of them on the top line as
causes of death
why is that well the top line of the
cause of death is really what you think
is the
the most important thing that
precipitated the death
um other things that you think played a
role in the death but were not direct
causes
get relegated to what's known as the
other significant conditions
part of the death certificate so the
other significant conditions are things
that played a role in the death
but didn't directly cause the death so
for example you know
mr floyd's use of fentanyl did not cause
the subduel or neck restraint his heart
disease did not cause
the um the subduel or the neck restraint
all right so so these are
items that may have contributed but
weren't the direct cause correct
forensic pathologist dr lindsey thomas
who's performed
more than five thousand post-mortem
examinations
told the court that the video footage of
the incident allowed her to rule out
that george floyd died of a fentanyl
overdose
if you put all this together
cardiopulmonary arrest
complicating law enforcement subduel
restraint
and neck compression what does that mean
well what it means to me
is that the activities of the law
enforcement officers resulted in mr
floyd's death
and that specifically those activities
were the subdual the restraint
and the net compression and does this
then also represent your own conclusion
yes a a conclusion you have reached an
opinion you hold to a reasonable degree
of medical certainty
yes uh would you tell us what you
reviewed in order to reach this
conclusion
um all of those things that i mentioned
earlier the
uh the
again what's sort of unique about this
case is
that often um i would just review the
medical examiner
case file and that would provide
information about what the cause and
manner of death is
but in this case the autopsy itself
didn't tell me the cause and manner of
death
and it really required getting
all of this other additional information
specifically
the video evidence of the terminal
events to
conclude the cause of death and manner
of death so then based on your
view review of the video and application
of your work experience and knowledge
uh did you rule out uh drug overdose
as a cause of death yes
and that's an opinion you hold to a
reasonable degree of medical certainty
yes
do you have an opinion to reasonable
degree of medical certainty
if mr floyd would have died that night
had he not been subject to
the uh subduel and restraint of the
police
there's no evidence to suggest he would
have died that night
except for the interactions with law
enforcement
the prosecution's expected to finish
presenting its case early next week
then it's the turn for the defense of
derrick chauvin
the trial resumes on monday